If
the soil here was brought from a residential area
, there might be black stones in the mountains around
it. It's a school that reclaimed a lake.
If you tie it up, it's a record of round and
cute creatures.  The wreckage and tires cannot be removed.
Expenditure record Black stone found. The soil is clayey, but the stones are visited.
[Music]
There is a reason for things.
Large monster robot
.
Is it okay to have a structure where I can't assemble my arms and look straight up?
Is it possible to protect the safety of the pilot
? Isn't it blamed by someone who has
become painful?  Robo It
's a lump of lies. Do
n't look at the sticks on your arms
. Don't shake your roots, but I can't write a Robo setting that everyone can agree on
.
The guy who writes the picture always says that.
You're 6 a lot twisted. I'm relieved
. There's also a tire.
This is daisuke. It's a
vehicle buggy that defeats monsters in place of this little robot.
[Music]
I can't accept it perfectly.  It's a conclusion that the contradiction was reached as a stepping stone at the increasing number of meetings.
The eyes of the viewers are harsh. If you take the trouble, the
robot police will immediately find out.
Giant robots are responsible, so robot animation production is a burden of inescapable sins. It's a
rule to die no matter which way you fall.